bonjour dernière édition du 7 8 l'aktu
pour cette saison voici les titres de ce
11 juillet est la fête nationale dans
quelques jours et pour les enfants
défavorisés participants à la journée
baptêmes de l'air à l'aéroport de vercia
et la surprise de voir au dessus de leur
tête la patrouille de france est début
et d'été pluvieux que nous réservent les
prochaines semaines premières tendances
à venir remarque avec météo france tout
à l'heure et puis comme chaque vendredi
ce qu'il faut retenir de la semaine
pistes de ski l encours inquiétudes dans
l'hôtellerie sur de nouvelles taxes et
puis crise à l'ump
pas de record pour jean à ridelles vous
allez voir les images dans un instant
pas de record pour jean ridel ce
cycliste de 80 noms qui s'est dit hier
est lancé sur la piste du vélodrome
nationale à montigny le bretonneux 29,4
146 le nombre de kilomètres qu'il aura
parcouru en une heure il échoue pour
quatre tours seulement soit 1 km il ne
devrait pas faire de nouvelle tentative
et déclare tout simplement s'être mis
trop de pression qui sont tombés et
comme dans le reste de la france ils
sont plus nombreux à l'avoir décroché
cette année dans l'académie de
versailles et toutes séries confondues
87,3 pour cent des candidats sont
admissibles
c'est 1,3 pour cent de plus que l'an
dernier cela s'explique par une forte
hausse en série technologique + 5 % et
au bac professionnel puisse 4%
à noter aussi que toutes catégories
confondues les résultats dans l'académie
sont meilleures dans les yvelines que
dans l'essonne les hauts-de-seine et
enfin le val d'oise politique et à l'ump
on en sait un peu plus sur l'audit
commandé par le triumvirat fillon juppé
raffarin près de 23 millions d'euros
dépensés en 2012 en congrès et
manifestations 1 millions d'euros en
2013 pour des dépenses en voyage et un
déficit qui avoisine les 75 millions
d'euros
un parti au bord du gouffre pour de
nombreux cadres de la formation la
députée des yvelines et chef du parti de
l'opposition dans département valérie
pécresse estime qu'il faut nettoyer tout
simplement l'ump elle
ne pas avoir soupçonné ce qu'il se
passait elle demande par ailleurs le
remboursement des billets d'avion payés
1 à dire copé pour accompagner son mari
jean-françois s'il est avéré que ces
sommes ont été indûment versés autre
réaction celle de rohr berger
conseillère politique à l'ump elle même
l'opposition dans la ville de magny les
hameaux proches de valérie pécresse elle
soutenait françois fillon face à la jean
françois copé lors de l'élection pour la
présidence du parti l'année dernière
elle milite depuis 12 ans deux partis
d'opposition
clairement on a vocation à l'ump a
vocation à demain pouvoir prétendre
avoir son candidat à la présidentielle
qui seraient durs 2017
ça ne pourrait être fait que sur les
milieux bancaires on a besoin d'un parti
plus décentralisée plus confiance à ses
fédérations ces départements en
particulier mocratique dans les prises
de décision et puis et que pensez vous
de cette situation à l'ump nous avons
nous vous avons posé la question voici
vos réponses
c'est scandaleux oui ça
ça nous interpelle quand même quelque
part quand et
on croit plus beaucoup
tous ces hommes politiques comme
considère qu'aujourd'hui l'environnement
politique actuel fait que c'est pas très
étonnant de voir toutes ces histoires
voilà on aimerait un petit peu plus de
politiques impliqués dans la vie des
gens et pas impliqués dans leur malheur
tout et n'importe quoi quoi
donc j'espère qu'ils vont faire un
changement complet de tous les gens de
l'ump
désabusé pas étonné un monde normal
quand le monde dans lequel on vit c'est
un peu c'est un peu un peu comme ça
c'est le reflet de ce conflit on va dire
je m'ennuie qu'une suite quoi qui est
enfin il soit inéligible
politique toujours derrière la réforme
territoriale la disparition des
départements si les contours de l'île de
france ne devrait pas évoluer les
conseils généraux qui la composent
subiront bien le même sort funeste que
dans le reste de l'hexagone dans les
yvelines l'actuel président du conseil
général pierre bédier n'apprécie pas
cette situation ce vendredi il s'en est
une fois de plus expliqué devant les
élus locaux les explications avec ce
sujet 2020 le compte à rebours est
enclenché les départements ne devrait
pas survivre à la réforme territoriale
l'état entend simplifier le millefeuille
administratif et faire des économies
quitte à sacrifier les conseils généraux
qui transféreront leurs compétences à
quatorze nouvelles régions une
disparition que les principaux concernés
ne sont pas prêts à accepter l'assemblée
des départements de france vient de
voter contre et dans les yvelines pierre
bédier se fait entendre dans un courrier
daté du 26 juin le président du conseil
général sollicité par le rapporteur du
projet de réforme s'interroge sur
l'urgence dans laquelle semaines les
débats
il souhaiterait la mise en place d'une
consultation populaire comme l'aurait
fait le général de gaulle et n'hésite
pas à parler d'un projet aussi mal
ficelé que bricoler jusqu'à la dernière
minute pour lui supprimer les
conseillers départementaux n'amènera pas
d'économie mais un éloignement des élus
du terrain et de regretter la
disparition des conseillers territoriaux
installé par le précédent président il
n'a été question que de défaire ce que
le gouvernement de nicolas sarkozy avait
édifié peut-on lire le bras de fer se
poursuit donc même si dans sa propre
famille politique l'heure n'est pas à
l'unité sur cette question valérie
pécresse candidate aux régionales en île
de france pour l'ump souhaite elle la
disparition des départements et non pas
en 2020
mais dès à présent une pétition circule
en ce moment à voisins le bretonneux
elle a été lancée à l'initiative de
parents d'élèves pour protester contre
la suppression annoncée à la rentrée des
bornes d'inscription dans les écoles
pour la cantine
au delà du conflit c'est l'ambiance au
sein de la commune que déplore la
nouvelle maire alexandra rosetti en
ajoutant que la décision a été prise par
la précédente équipe
alexis piette maire lors du précédent
mandat elle dément cette affirmation il
demande le retrait du projet ils
demandent aussi une concertation avec
les habitants
il conclut au nom de son groupe
d'opposition en parlant de confusion et
d'amateurisme dans la gestion du dossier
par la nouvelle équipe majoritaire nous
quittons la politique
le 14 juillet et son traditionnel défilé
nous intéresse à présent les dernières
répétitions avant les champs elysées se
déroule en ce moment sur la base
militaire à satory l'occasion pour nous
de rencontrer des élèves officiers de
l'école de la gendarmerie nationale et
défilent pour la première fois le
reportage de catherine vu la toya
l'intérêt est clair combien et quand je
les opus yeux la gendarmerie nationale
alors comment objets non
stoïque sous la pluie ces élèves de
l'école des officiers de la gendarmerie
répètent leur dernier mouvement leurs
derniers pas un pas précis et bien
évidemment coordonner le 14 juillet
défileront sur les champs elysées sur
une distance précise de 800 m en ce
mercredi pluvieux ses élèves officiers
se trouve à satory pour une répétition
générale avec les autres corps militaire
quand je voyais les défilés à la télé
non j'imagine n'est pas le travail qui
peut y avoir derrière c'est sûr on a
l'impression que c'est facile d'avoir
tout le monde bien aligné avec les mains
qui qui arrive au même moment au même
endroit et c'est tout vient du mien
propre et puis en fait c'est beaucoup de
travail parce que chaque individu en
fait tu peux tout faire chez un tout
chambouler tout moment et donc vraiment
très concentré
c'est du détail ça c'est pas si ça se
voit pour ainsi mais c'est vrai que
énormément de choses là à penser le port
de tête 9 fourreau donc ce qu'on porte
voilà c'est du détail c'est très
minutieux mais ça fait toute la
différence
on a tous des filles au début de l'année
quand on commence à faire des cérémonies
à répéter c'est pas facile ça commence à
venir au fur et à mesure de la cohésion
dans le groupe aussi la cohésion du
groupe indispensable pour ces élèves qui
seront amenés dans deux ans a dirigé des
équipes de 30 à 40 personnes
la préparation du défilé du 14 juillet
une étape dans leur cursus éducatif à
prendre au mieux est donc de faire
l'effort sur eux-mêmes d'être ouvert
d'autres comme ils sont actuellement sur
cette belle génération y qui souhaitent
comprendre ce qu'elle fait mais qui est
également apprend à être humble apprend
à obéir aux ordres à donner le meilleur
d'elle-même à s'engager dans l'effort un
engagement que chacun pourra constater
lundi 14 juillet l'occasion du défilé
militaire sur les champs elysées
assurément une grande fierté pour ses
102 élèves de l'école de gendarmerie
c'est vraiment laid ce n'était connue
c'est une grande chance pour nous de
pouvoir le décembre c'est aussi une
façon de réaffirmer notre militarité de
montrer qu'on fait partie la communauté
militaire donc en tant que gendarme
on a rarement le lien avec des citoyens
mais
le public donc c'est bien d'avoir ce
retour ce jour là j'espère que qu'on
sera beau
et cette fête nationale s'annonce
particulière pour les enfants
défavorisés participants à la journée
baptêmes de l'air à l'aéro club de
versailles je reçois jean louis lemay
bonjour joli nom de l'aéro club de
versailles et david benhamou bienvenue
en plateau également pdg de sce dvi
groupe vous êtes partenaires de cette
opération et vous allez donc offrir aux
enfants la patrouille de france et
l'équipe de voltige de l'armée de l'air
très juillet 11h30
comment ça va se passer bah écoutez ça
va se passer au mieux je l'espère selon
la météo parce que la météo en aviation
c'est toujours un aléa
nous allons avoir les enfants qui vont
arriver dimanche matin
jusqu'à 11 heures la patrouille de
france feront vers 11h15 pas passer et
où pour le grand bénéfice des enfants
bien sûr et nous aurons également au sol
les avions de la voltige de l'équipe de
voltige de l'armée de l'air qui seront
là avec les pilotes
le capitaine cam dit il le capitaine
leveau françois leveaux qui est champion
du monde de voltige et également des
pilotes de l'armée de l'air de deux
mirage 2000 qui seront là aussi un
moment d'exception comment ça a été
rendu possible une telle opération
cette opération si vous voulez été
rendue possible grâce à david david
benhamou en 2011 2011 c'était une année
exceptionnelle pour nous une année
charnière c'était le centenaire de
l'hérault club de versailles est donc
dans toutes nos animations nous avons
préparé des événements est un événement
que nous souhaitions mettre en place
c'était mais faire donner un peu de
bonheur aux enfants défavorisés et leur
faire faire des baptêmes
il nous fallait pour ça un partenariat
est donc nous avons trouvé en la période
de notre ami david maintenant un
partenariat sur sur cette année 2011
partenariat qui s'est prolongée l'année
suivante et depuis 2000 depuis quatre
ans maintenant on fait chaque année
quatre événements de ce genre avec les
enfants défavorisés de la région avec
les différentes associations des
hôpitaux alors expliquer justement
comment vous vous êtes arrivé sur ce
projet parce qu'on vous ait sollicité
vous faisiez peut-être partie déjà dû de
méreau club je vais préciser donc vous
êtes le pdg fondateur d'une société pme
qui pourrait être très très clair très
transparent s'occupe de tout ce qui est
sécurité cellules ml j cote tels que ça
parle me lave absolument clé beaucoup
plus connu sous le nom de digicode à la
rend en fait nous fabriquons nous
concevons nous fabriquons des produits
de contrôle d'accès et ça c'est le
travail de tous les jours et au delà de
ça c'est un plaisir familial que de
faire de l'aviation c'est ce qui nous a
réuni jean louis
tout était terminé à arriver dans cette
aventure là avec cette société
alors seulement et donc l'idée de jean
louis à l'origine c'était de donner ce
plaisir aux enfants de leur donner du
bonheur
quels autres moyens que l'autre plaisir
que de donner du bonheur ses enfants en
les faisant voler en leur donnant la
possibilité très précisément non plus
drôle devait regarder depuis le sol et
regarder un avion au ciel mais d'être
dans l'avion et c'est émerveillement con
qu'on partage à chaque fois qu'on a
cette activité à chaque fois qu'on a
cette action de regarder ses enfants mes
cendres avec ses étoiles qui brille dans
les yeux non plus dans le ciel mais dans
les yeux de ses enfants défavorisés
alors pour ça évidemment jean louis
travail avec tous ces hôpitaux
peut-être que tu voudrais des sites et
des sentiments qui vont à la fois
découvrir à la patrouille de france
et en plus aussi s'envoler et y voir
bien sûr à entraver que l'hôpital andré
mignot le l'hôpital necker l'hôpital
robert debré raymond poincaré le secours
populaire aussi qui est très actif
les apprentis d'auteuil l'institut
gustave roussy les assos l'association
des paralysés de france le foyer grand
champ de de liste des yvelines et
l'association de parents d'enfants
inadaptés
ça fait énormément d'enfants ça fait
beaucoup d'enfants savez chaque session
nous prenons une cinquantaine d'enfants
sur la journée et on arrive regardez au
bout de quatre ans atteindre 1500 sa ses
1120 la rampe qui aurait cru ça à
l'époque s'est félicité vraiment génial
et alors pour les moniteurs s'ils sont
qu'un cas l'expérience les antilles ont
parlé des enfants on vous disent ils
sont émerveillés mais pour les moniteurs
aussi c'est un moment particulier les
oui ce sont des pilotes qui sont tout à
fait adaptées pour
et qualifié pour faire les baptêmes de
l'air mais à chaque fois eux mêmes sont
se prennent au jeu quoi parce que vous
avez des enfants qui ont une
appréhension quand ils montent dans
l'avion
et quand ils descendent ils ont des yeux
mais écarquillés et certains même
enfants d'ailleurs fait c'est assez
j'irai pas courant mais il y en a qui le
font c'est qu'ils s'arrangent pour
tourner et pour revenir faire un tour
c'est vous dire qu'ils ont eu du plaisir
on en parlait encore tout à l'heure ses
enfants s'en occupe depuis leur arrivée
il ya deux sessions globalement dans la
journée on s'arrange pour que dès leur
arrivée on va s'en occuper on va leur
montrer on va leur parler de l'avion on
va leur expliquer ce que c'est que
l'avion on va leur expliquer ce que sont
ces manettes c'est ces instruments de
vol à quoi ils servent
et évidemment c'est un émerveillement
pas seulement pour eux pour être honnête
c'est aussi un émerveillement pour nous
que de voir ses enfants profitaient du
fait d'aller voler et de découvrir
l'aviation l'aviation civile à 100 ans
l'aéro club à 100 ans et ça fait parler
de chose justement qu'est l'aviation et
en particulier la création en france
c'est d'autant plus particulier cette
année que ce sera pour 14 juillet pour
la fête nationale et mère d'un petit peu
l'historique justement de de l'aéro club
le 14 juillet a toujours été particulier
chaque année depuis la création au tout
début
à l'occasion du 14 juillet en ballons
ont été lâchés c'est ça devant le thème
de la préfecture de ralliement à vue de
parer tout à fait oublier toujours une
tradition de basse et ses 14 juillet
pour le oui enfin c'est surtout le les
possibilités qui nous sont offertes de
pouvoir le faire
ceci dit volée la veille du 14 juillet
où les jours précédents c'est pas
évident parce que nous avons dans la
région les entraînements ddd comment
dirais-je des avions qui vont défiler
sur les champs elysées et donc on a des
contraintes si vous voulez un petit peu
bon sauf le 13 la sof dimanche où là
tout est déjà verrouillé donc on est
tranquille pour le faire ce que je
voudrais dire aussi dans l'accueil des
enfants c'est que monsieur benhamou et
et sa société non seulement offrent les
baptêmes mais également l'accueil des
enfants le petit déjeuner le matin
repas de midi le goûter du cadre de
quatre heures je peux vous assurer que
les enfants sont émerveillés et meyriez
et les parents aussi
pour conclure juste effectivement sur
cet aspect social aussi le club l'a
toujours eue à quel moment il ya eu
cette volonté c est venu de vous c'est
dans un club on travaille on travaille à
plusieurs il ya pas d aiea le président
qui est là pour diriger un petit peu
mais il ya aussi les idées qui viennent
des uns et des autres et c'est cette
idée de baptême
c'était c'est venu d'un de nos adhérents
pierre-emmanuel sud pour ne pas le
nommer qui a eu l'idée d'organiser ces
baptêmes et donc on s'est dit ben on y
va banco combien d'enfants demain le 13
juillet pardon de la balle en honneur à
50 50 enfants
merci donc à tous à tous les deux et
merci à vous vous êtes partenaires
maintenant fait on est associé le 6 le
13 juillet ses enfants défavorisés ou
malades qui vont donc lors d'une journée
de baptême de l'air en plus petite
cerise sur le gâteau la patrouille de
france au dessus de leur tête merci
encore à vous que nous faisons une pause
à présent dans ce journal avec la
diffusion d'un court métrage
il est signé du centre d'enseignement
des soins d'urgence des yvelines la mort
de notre confrère le journaliste benoît
duquesne nous rappelle une triste
réalité
chaque année en france quarante mille
personnes sont victimes d'un arrêt
cardio respiratoire dans 75% des cas ces
arrêts se déroule devant des témoins et
dans seulement 10 % des cas les gestes
qui sauvent sont pratiquées dans votre
pays au contraire des pays nordiques par
exemple il n'ya pas de formation aux
premiers secours regarder ce court
métrage et on se retrouve dans 5 minutes
toujours en plateau
ah ah ah ah ah
enfin ça ça ne ramènera pas voulu au
fait j'en dernier message de la part des
jets radier coupé alban on n'est pas au
théâtre
alors tu es un gangster je vais te le
faire j'ai un dernier message de la part
des gérants viti pour moi tu vois je
suis pas comédien je fais mieux que toi
d'accord je suis désolé j'ai tic n'est
pas ce que je pensais vraiment pourtant
mon rôle comme on aime et alban ne pense
pas joue les tic
oui augus oui mais ça ne nous regarde
pas parfait mais que nous fait la même
chose c'était que c'était formidable
les moteurs demandé ça ton annonce 22
sur un 15e à a et actions enfin ça ne
ramènera pas voulu au fait j'ai un
dernier message de la part des gérald y
couper
qu'est ce que tu attends des pauvres
pour tirer non mais j'aurais dû tirer
avant à 8 ans réduite en réduit à 8 ans
va du mais je m'y attendais pas
entreprendre
je suis désolé enfin je crois qu'il ya
un problème là oui je sais ce que je dis
non il ya un vrai problème
silence auguste est ce que tu m'entends
il sert mais n'enregistrent j'en passe
on souffle sur mon visage je l'entends
pas l'air qui sort je vois pas ma main
bouge et il inconscient il respire pas
c'est un arrêt cardiaque
qu'est-ce qu'on fait qu'est-ce qu'on
fait julia qu'est-ce qu'on fait alban
jacky appelle le samu en composant le 15
noeuds l'adresse explique la situation
la situation oui un homme 38 enfin un
arrêt cardiaque
on va débuter la réanimation allez
dépêche-toi robin tulard audiard à
l'entrée du studio il ya un
défibrillateur recherché pencheront ce
massage cardiaque hockey qu'au niveau du
thorax
les bras bien tendus et perpendiculaires
100 fois par minute
il arrive c'est bon c'est bon il est pas
tous corps devait le tuer au nom qu'il
faut enfoncer le thorax de 4 à 6 cm tu
peux me chanter son single like s'il te
plaît ne décolle pas du tout c'est
rythme parfait pour un massage cardiaque
entre 100 et 120 pression par minute
leur frère c'est une serena lab aaa
c'est là
à
hu
qu'est ce que je ferais pas soin
électronique du rythme cardiaque ou faux
pas lui faire du bouche à bouche ne pas
toucher à ses taux recommandé quoi
chèque comme un des appareils en charge
restez à l'écart du patient des vivres
et le choc
maintenant appuyer sur la touche aux
chocs des vivres et des voix là c'est
parfait merci à ces mots là
il y a un aura respecté faites le 15
massage cardiaque défibrillation soins
spécialisés
il
nous reprenons le cours de ce journal du
7 8 l'aktu pour s'attarder à l'essentiel
de la semaine et la contestation qui
s'amplifie autour de la création d'une
piste de ski elle en course et plus
précisément un ski dôme portés par une
société privée au sommet de la colline
de la ville qui inquiète les élus
souhaitent valoriser le site les
opposants craignent pollution et
dépenses exorbitantes
on écoute à présent olivier parent et
jacquot secrétaire d'europe écologie les
verts dans le département ils étaient
présents sur ce plateau ont longuement
d'une réunion publique organisée en
mairie d'elancourt pour présenter ce
projet je pense que on a de nos jours un
certain nombre d' alerte que ce soit des
alertes par exemple des experts du giec
le dossier est sorti il ya quelques mois
donc qui nous alerte sur le fait que le
réchauffement climatique est quelque
chose qui est due à l'activité humaine
un des dossiers du dia qui est aussi
très intéressant puisqu'il nous disent
que ce n'est pas inéluctable c'est à
dire que effectivement il ya des choses
qui sont dues à l'activité humaine mais
que l'on peut imaginer recorrigé
atténuer les effets et donc qui dit
atténuer les effets dit ne pas se lancer
dans des projets qui vont à l'encontre
du fait de consommer de l'énergie
là où c'est pas nécessairement utile
donc c'est pas nécessairement qu'ils
qu'il faut tout arrêter qu'il faut plus
rien faire simplement on n'est pas
nécessairement obligé de continuer à
faire des projets qu'ils soient
consommateurs et d'énergie imaginez un
hangar de plus de 300 mètres de long sur
50 à 100 mètres de large le maintenir à
5 degrés pendant toute l'année y compris
en été c'est quand même quelque chose
qui va consommer des milliers de
kilowattheures des millions de
kilomètres de kilowattheures cafouillage
autour de la taxe de séjour ce
prélèvement que peuvent percevoir les
communes françaises reconnues station de
tourisme après la décision de
l'assemblée nationale de procéder à une
révision des tarifs jusqu'à 8 euros pour
un hôtel de 3 à 5 étoiles et même une
hausse supplémentaire de 2 euros en
ile-de-france pour financer les
transports le gouvernement à parler
d'erreur le texte a donc été amendée
hier jeudi mais il doit encore être
votée invité cette semaine sur le
plateau philippin de l'union hôtelière
dont les yvelines
et pour lui la simple idée
une hausse va empêcher les touristes de
rester plus longtemps
il a évoqué sur ce plateau une image est
tout simplement se tirer une balle dans
le pied
va-t-il réagir comment on va se
positionner à cet organisme nous le
verrons d'ici la rentrée un tout autre
sujet une météo peu engageante cette
semaine jeudi le thermomètre n'a pas
dépassé les 14 degrés un temps d'automne
diront certains et pourtant nous sommes
bien au moins à 2 juillet nous sommes
tout de même à la lgv est rectifié
auprès de météo france
doudoune pour certaines blousons chauds
pour d'autres ces images n'ont pas été
filmé en plein mois de novembre mais ce
jeudi 10 juillet à montigny le
bretonneux
le thermomètre ne dépasse pas les 14
degrés sous abri 12 degrés en
température ressentie avec ce petit vent
frisquet qui viennent vous chatouiller
bref nous sommes 10 degrés en dessous
des normales saisonnières
pas de record mais pas loin à trappes
on a un historique de données depuis
1904 et donc on a eu un précédent record
à 12 degrés le 10 juillet 1948 mais on
n'en est pas loin
on a aussi bien au sol qu'en altitude
une dépression sur l'est de la france
qui dirige surtout pays un flux de nord
comme on peut le constater bien humide
avec beaucoup d'humilité de basses
couches beaucoup du aschbach beaucoup de
pluie aussi en quatre jours il est tombé
40 à 50 millimètres d'eau soit presque
l'équivalent d'un mois de pluie en
juillet la faute également un
anticyclone des açores chargé de nous
amener du beau temps et pour l'heure
bloquée sur l'atlantique
il faut rester confiant le week-end sera
meilleure avec des températures de 20 à
22 degrés et surtout pas de pluie qu'en
est il pour le mois de juillet toutes
précautions prises
isabelle deschamps décrit un temps mi
figue mi raisin on peut penser que cette
période très fraîche et très humide va
quand même prendre fin mais qu'on ne
voit toujours pas quand même
l'anticyclone des açores s'installer sur
le nord de la france donc un peut
présumer une alternance de deux belles
journées et deux journées perturbées
avec des températures entre 20 et 24
degrés en moyenne quelques journées plus
chaudement face c'est en gros comme ça
que se profile le mois de juillet en
tout cas pour ceux qui cherchent la
chaleur rendez vous mercredi prochain le
thermomètre devrait approcher les 28
degrés messi merci de nous avoir suivis
tout au long de cette saison le journal
revient le 1er septembre sur téléfilm
merci aux équipes techniques et merci
également à la rédaction qui a travaillé
tout au long de l'année sur les
reportages et sur les différents
plateaux je vous souhaite un très bel
été